In this next section, I want to do a quick overview of the ICD-FX camera and frustrum.
Now, we set this up already in our end display configuration, but we need to talk a little
bit about the ICD-FX camera and frustrum if you're not familiar with these terms.
So understanding the way the inner frustrum and outer frustrum work on your end display
configuration is really going to be important.
The inner frustrum is the region of your LED wall that is actually going to show
up on screen and in camera.
That's what your camera sees.
It's the actual field of view, the focal length, the zoom of your real camera.
This is enabled by creating your ICD-FX camera, as we did before, and connecting it to the
live-length tracked camera, just as we did.
Now the outer frustrum is everything else.
It's used for reflections, dynamic lighting, and it remains static while your camera moves
around.
Now the engine does support multiple frustrums, but to set up your frustrum, I just want
to review the steps to create your ICD-FX camera and create your tracked object.
So we're going to start out in the engine here inside our end display configuration.
So first thing I'm going to do is I'm going to edit my NDC asset, and I'm going
to take a look here and point out that I've got my ICD-FX camera.
Now I want to make sure that this matches, so I'm just going to go ahead and change
the name here.
I'm going to use ICD-FX as the naming on this, and I'm going to change this to
match the camera we're actually using.
So on stage, this is my Blackmagic ZEISS camera.
This way, I know what I'm actually connecting to.
I'm going to go ahead and hit compile and save this.
Now if I select this, you can see I've got to send a camera actor that's in here,
and I've got several options that are available to me once that's ready.
Now I'm going to hide this and come back to that, because they're going to see
some changes here.
Now this is my ICD-FX camera.
With my end display configuration selected, if I select my ICD-FX camera underneath
my NDC asset, you can see that this is the selected camera.
Now I need something here to add to it, so I'm going to create some objects here.
I'm going to move up to my Place Actors panel, and I'm going to move into my
basic section, and I'm going to add in an empty actor.
Now this empty actor, I'm going to really quickly rename to Tracking Offset.
Then I'm going to move this underneath my NDC asset.
Now if yours doesn't connect, it's because you're not actually in your end display
config level.
Remember, we are in the NDC level, not the persistent level, in order to add in our
tracked offset in order to parent that underneath our NDC asset.
Next, let's just zero out our location and our rotation information.
This way, we're at our origin position that matches our offset inside motive.
Now, I do need a camera here.
That camera is going to take over for our NDC asset.
If I zoom in really quickly, you can see this little pop here.
This little pop-up where we've got some sky, that's our inner frustrum.
If I select my NDC asset and I select my ICVFX camera that's listed in here,
you can see I've got an Enable Inner Frostrum option checked on.
If I turn that off, turn it back on, this section pops in and out.
Now I'm going to zoom back out a little bit, switch over in my Place Actors
to the Cinematic tab.
I'm going to grab my Cine Camera Actor and just drag this into place,
so it's in the level.
Now, I'm going to rename this one to my NDC Blackmagic Zeiss Camera.
And the reason I'm going to call it that is that this is the NDC's
version of that camera.
Now, I'm going to go ahead and parent this underneath my tracking offset so
that this takes all that information for calibration later.
Now, I'm going to go ahead and zero this out.
And then with my tracked object in here, I need to add a component
to this camera.
That camera component that I'm going to add is with my Zeiss camera selected,
hit Add Component, and add another Live Link Component Controller.
I'm going to change the name of this one to Live Link CC, so LLCC,
Live Link Component Controller.
I'm going to call this one Blackmagic Zeiss Track.
It's for tracking the camera.
That's what we're going to use this for.
It's going to use my scene component.
I'm going to use my subject representation and choose my Blackmagic Active
because I'm using my active tracking object.
That's going to pop this into place.
And once this is ready to go, I can move back up to my NDC asset
in my Outliner, choose my ICVFX Camera, and right under here where I've got
my Cine Camera Actor, I can select my Blackmagic Zeiss Camera so that my
inner frustum is now being run through this camera and not the ICVFX Camera,
which you'll note disappears.
Now, I can also enable an inner frustum border, which if I change to 0.1,
you can start to see show up.
0.5 makes it thick enough so that it actually shows up on screen.
But I'm going to settle it at 0.25.
It's just enough to see but not enough to be in the way.
Now, I can also change my border color.
So, as I know, Sean is a little partial to green.
Let's go ahead and make a nice little green there.
And that's our outline.
Now, there is also some overscan options.
If I enable overscan for my frustum, I can also make sure that this
shows up on screen.
And if I change that to 1.2, my frustum gets bigger.
This way, if my subject is in front of my camera, I can make sure that my
frustum aligns to outside of my camera's view and there is no tearing.
That way, if I have any kind of move or anything like that,
this will actually give me a bit of a buffer so that as my camera moves,
it kind of goes through and follows along.
Now, let's jump back to our slides and let's talk about your ICD-FX camera
and inner frustums.
Now, the ICD-FX camera does support multiple frustums.
You just add in, the same as we did before, another camera,
you iterate that or give it the same name of a new camera that you're using,
and then track that camera in there as well.
You can also use the Live Link V-Cam with a Pixel streaming server to
generate a second camera and use that as well for more virtual camera work.
Note, as you move through your NDC camera with the two inner frustums,
it is recommended that you limit yourself to just two frustums.
You can also set the priority of your frustum so that the main frustum for
your camera is the one that overlaps.
That way, your secondary camera doesn't necessarily override that as well.
So that finishes up our discussion on cameras,
and we are ready to move on to our next section.